this is the man in Prime position to be
Thailand's new prime minister Peter Lim
German the leader of the move forward
party winners of Sunday's election I
think it's fair to say that it's the
sentiment of the era that has changed
and the job or the duty of Member of
Parliament is to speak on the behalf of
people is to pass Progressive laws is to
make sure that we support the duty of
the government and that was my past Duty
now I'm the government
the incumbent General prayer Channel
left party headquarters briskly on
Sunday night the rejection of the
pro-military parties by voters makes his
return very unlikely her tie that came
second said it would join a coalition
government would move forward
it conceded it's now the junior partner
in that Coalition a humbling statement
for a political force that's dominated
Thai politics for two decades
thought we would be number one however
we accept it because it is the
sportsmanship of the party that achieved
first place
move forward success could be a
considerable threat to the establishment
it's displaced the military has a
symbiotic relationship with the monarchy
so you know this is these are the
established centers of power that that
really run Thailand for many decades so
I don't expect them to go away quietly
but I also don't expect them to resort
to a military coup right away for the
moment though it's time to celebrate a
hard-won victory three years ago student
protests started here at democracy
Monument calling for reform of the
government and the monarchy the
government at the time cracked down
arresting many of the student leaders
they didn't extinguish the desire for
reform which is now led to the victory
in this election have moved forward
as crowds gathered in the late afternoon
they waited for the man who'd led the
party right to the top
his arrival greeted with screams and
cheers
and with colleagues who only last night
were elected to Parliament he set off on
a Victory lap
Tony Chang Al Jazeera Bangkok